bonjour 21 juin c'est l'été et c'est le
bac l'été pour tout le monde puisqu'il
fait à peu près beau sur l'ensemble de
la france nous verrons ça dans un
instant avec l'opéra et le baccalauréat
pour 337 milles candidat depuis ce matin
8h ils sont en course avec le premier
obstacle qui est l'épreuve de
philosophie on a commencé par la philo
en effet pour la plupart des sections
parce que c'est l'épreuve la plus longue
à corriger et parce qu'aussi semble-t-il
les correcteurs sont moins nombreux que
dans les autres matières en somme c'est
une confirmation de la tendance il y a
de moins en moins de littéraires et de
philosophes il y a de plus en plus de
scientifiques puisque le bac technique
cette année mobilise plus de cent mille
candidats c'est-à-dire un tiers du total
donc dans ce journal aussi d'autres
sujets importants de cette actualité le
conseil des ministres l'évacuation de
lusine flins chez renault cette nuit le
vote de l'assemblée nationale sur la
répression et la prévention de l'alcool
au volant
sans oublier bien sûr le football ce
soir
tout cela dans un instant mais tout de
suite nous allons nous rendre à la
sortie de la première épreuve du
baccalauréat
c'est un peu une tradition devant le
lycée buffon à paris nous retrouvons
maurice olivari qui interroge pour nous
quelques candidats
je lance un policier au lycée buffon ce
sont les candidats dans la série à qui
planche depuis ce matin à 8h sur la
matière qui est la plus importante pour
eux c'est la philosophie je vous soumets
tout de suite les trois sujets comme à
l'habitude qui leur ont été soumis être
égaux s être identique premier sujet
deuxième sujet quand peut-on dire d'un
événement qu'il appartient au passé
troisième sujet enfin dégager l'intérêt
philosophique d'un test d'un texte de
blaise pascal
sur qu'est ce que le mois alors
messieurs dames quels sont les sujets
que vous avez choisi par prédilection
alors parce que j'ai pris le 2 parce que
pour moi philosophie suez sérieuse aux
filles elles c'est ça je crois que c'est
important à dire parce que ça c'est
important
voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire
quelques déficiences et coefficient 4
alors c'est assez important c'est une
épreuve importante que ce qu'on appelle
important quels sont les sujets que vous
avez eu l'occasion de traiter bon
l'année le langage mais ce ne sont pas
les sujets que vous avez le sujet
difficile
d'abord elles sont tous très difficile
jugé difficile vous avez choisi le calme
choisi notre sujet ce le tec ses caisses
que
est-ce que moi qu'est-ce que le mois
recule pas facile ou difficile pour eux
pas très difficile parce que comme le
moi c'est la partie consciente du
psychisme donc c'est pas trop trop
difficile jugé que j'avais eu l'occasion
de traiter pendant l'année non non non
je n'aime pas vraiment l'habitude de
faire la même chose qu'au bac mais dix
ans et il n'est pas si difficile que ça
que la suite des opérations maintenant
la prochaine épreuve
la prochaine épreuve ça va être dit sa
géographie l'anglais c'est le 27
oui ce sont des sujets assez classique
espérons que ces candidats ont développé
est au fait un peu leurs arguments la
presse tous vos journaux sont remplis de
chiffres de statistique d'analysé à
propos de ce fameux baccalauréat comme
si toute la france était candidate
bachelière c'est loin d'être le cas
mais enfin cette épreuve si elle n'ouvre
pas toutes les portes en ferme beaucoup
en cas d'échec et elle concerne plus de
300 mille familles avec dominique laurie
nous allons consulter les premiers
intéressés pour voir ce qu'il ce qu'ils
pensent eux de ce bac la parole aux
candidats donc parce que je pense que
samba qu'on peut prendre universités
l'attrayante and the thud édition n'a
pas le ballon peut pas
donc il faut le baccalauréat dans
l'église sainte 300 d'avoir certainement
nous faut des mentions vous certaines
choses pour entrer dans les rangs des
écoles mais à la base c'est un peu le
pied dans l'étrier 156 rien à mon avis
est important puisque si son ouverture
vers l'avenir
le dic à son actuel effet de construit
de telle manière que 101 bat maintenant
pour passer à autre chose
oui il ya un peu dévaluée dans le sens
d'avoir le bac il faut avoir le bac une
certaine façon avec une mention sans
mention c'était là le bac
enfin ça ne permet pas la fin des
grandes écoles donc il est d'évaluer ce
point de vue là bas sinon bon c'est
toucher toujours toujours un moyen pour
faire quelque chose n'est pas une fin en
soi
avec les bleus bas qu'on n'ait rien mis
sans le bac on est strictement rien
c'est vraiment votre sentiment
l'agent celui-ci est bon personne n'est
pas ce que l'on rentre dans une
entreprise en aura son bac bô le patron
s'en apercevoir s'en apercevra mais non
on y fera pas attention mais si on
arrive pour se présenter sans son bac
vous est ce qui vous pose un homme
en fait il ya le bac à bac b avec des
vaccins et c'est que même les pacsés qui
remporte le plus de chance
oui je pense que le bac représente la
capacité d'élèves de de retenir toute
une année de travail avec eux les
contrôles continus fonds porte sur une
partie du programme seulement et c'est
pas vraiment si c'est pas il est alors
trop pour contre les
je pense que l'examen de fin d'année
combat c'est un travail de toutes les
années de synthèse de deux volontés
énorme aussi parce que le bac c'est
c'est pas si facile que ça on n'en fut
pas d'accord le bac
attention il faut travailler le break au
bout et travaillé toute l'année est
régulièrement pour ans oui mais si vous
êtes d'accord
je trouve que c'est un peu injuste de
juger un élève sur deux jours de cours
alors que en fait il peut très bien
avoir un accident ce jour là
nous avons été très bons
le visuel même si on s'enfonce s'engage
dans une voie pour les grandes études
on sait que c'est bouché déjà vraiment
de médecine architecture donc même en
faisant énormément d'études en en
consacrant sept ans de sa vie premier
études on sait très bien que ça va être
bouché alors nous demandent comment
faire
vous pensez de tout la même chose soit
vous savez que c'est bouché ou du parent
et quand vous demandez quelle branche ou
quelle section brobo ce qui bouge pas
atmosphère studieuse aussi sans aucun
doute pour le conseil des ministres de
ce matin avec des communications
importantes notamment de madame simone
la ministre de la santé et de monsieur
rené monory le ministre de l'économie de
l'économie sera largement question dans
un entretien en tête à tête cora je vous
le rappelle le président giscard
d'estaing vendredi à hambourg avec le
chancelier fédéral
helmut schmidt les deux hommes d'état
prépareront le conseil européen de brême
et le sommet économique occidentale de
bonnes en juillet nous rejoindront dans
un instant bruno masure à l'elysée en
attendant la suite de l'actualité avec
claude gérard renault à flins l'atelier
dé presse a été évacuée ce matin par les
forces de police qui ont pénétré à
l'intérieur de l'usiné vers 3h30
l'évacuation s'est déroulée sans
incident un commentaire de françois
c'est entre 3 et 4 heures cette nuit que
les forces de police accompagnée de crs
et de gendarmes mobiles évacua centaine
de grévistes qui occupent l'atelier des
grandes presse à l' usine de flins
l'opération se déroule sans aucun
incident les grévistes s'attendait à
cette évacuation
il s'y attendait depuis la décision du
tribunal de versailles autorisant la
régie à faire intervenir les forces de
l'ordre pour permettre le libre accès
des ateliers presse
à 4h30
tout est terminé mais grévistes quittent
l'enceinte de lusine les forces de
police s'installe aux portes et à
l'intérieur et lorsque l'équipe du matin
non touchés par le chômage technique
arrive pour prendre le travail il y a
beaucoup de confusion interrompu lundi
la négociation direction-syndicats la
négociation sur les revendications des
os en vert pourrait reprendre saab après
midi le tribunal de caen a ordonné
l'évacuation de lusine de
cormelles-le-royal dans le calvados de
son côté le préfet de l'orne est
intervenu en rencontrant des
représentants de l'intersyndicale
bouline ex cela devrait permettre une
prochaine rencontre syndicats/direction
à lyon au troisième jour de grève des
conducteurs de métro la réunion d'hier
n'ayant donné aucun résultat
à la rochelle 50 patrons pêcheurs ont
décidé de se joindre au mouvement
déclenché par les marins pêcheurs de
l'aiguillon en vendée à à royan
charente-maritime grève décidée afin
d'exiger des dérogations après les
mesures gouvernementales qui impose des
nouveaux critères pour la taille du
poisson et le maillage des chaluts 450
bateaux sont immobilisés les marins de
la cotinière dans l'île d'oléron d'où
est parti le mouvement se sont
constitués en syndicat professionnel
depuis le début de l'année cent mille
personnes ont adhéré au parti communiste
c'est ce qu'annonce à communiquer du
communiqué du comité central une
campagne d'adhésion est prévue pendant
l'été afin de dépasser 700 mille membres
à la fin de cette année cet après midi
en conclusion des travaux du comité
central georges marchais donnera une
conférence de presse à 15h à l'assemblée
nationale le groupe rpr s'est plaint des
difficultés qui sont faites à jacques
chirac dans les préparatifs de son
voyage en polynésie voyage prévu pour le
mois de juillet le député rpr de
polynésie a indiqué que les directives
précises avaient été données par
l'intermédiaire de paul dijoux le
secrétaire d'état aux départements et
territoires d'outre-mer pour ne pas
mettre à la disposition de jacques
chirac
les moyens qu'on offre généralement à
n'importe quel visiteur claude labbé le
président du groupe parlementaire rpr
indiqué qu'ils allaient s'entretenir
avec le premier ministre de cette
affaire qu'il considère comme grave
le gouvernement déposera à l'automne
prochain un projet de loi pour une vaste
réforme nécessaire et attendue par les
maires mais aussi un peu redoutée la
réforme des collectivités locales c'est
pourquoi avant de mettre un texte au
point le gouvernement a tenu à consulter
les intéressait c'était l'objet d'un
large débat au sénat au cours de la nuit
on a examiné les problèmes immédiats des
communes et leur évolution à long terme
la situation actuelle des collectivités
locales jakin collins tout le monde est
d'accord il faut donner aux
municipalités plus d'autonomie et
permettre aux citoyens de participer
effectivement à la vie de leur commune
mais le moyen pour y arriver sont
difficiles à trouver après le rapport
guichard le vaste questionnaire envoyé à
chacun des trente six mille maires pour
leur permettre d'exprimer leurs souhaits
et les travaux des différentes
associations d'élus on peut cependant
dégagées et les principaux points à
réformer et conseillers municipaux
demandent à être responsable de
l'exécution de leurs décisions
ils souhaitent la suppression de la
tutelle a priori des préfets et de
l'administration
les élus locaux veulent avoir plus de
pouvoir en ce qui concerne l'urbanisme
ils veulent la maîtrise totale des
permis de construire ils veulent aussi
pouvoir entreprendre des travaux plus
rapidement qu actuellement il demande à
l'état le remboursement intégral de la
tva une nouvelle répartition du montant
de l'impôt
la plupart souhaitent que les
subventions occasionnels soit remplacée
par une dotation globale
les maires sont favorables dans
l'ensemble à une coopération entre
différentes communes mais ils veulent
pouvoir choisir la ou les communes avec
lesquels ils coopéreront et choisir les
domaines d'activité comme que ce soit le
ramassage scolaire ou l'aménagement des
routes
rappelons que depuis l'entrée en vigueur
de la loi de 1971
on a enregistré 900 entente de fusion de
communes sur 36 milles
les conseillers municipaux veulent
pouvoir disposer d'un temps minimum pour
s'occuper des affaires de leur commune
certains souhaitent avoir un véritable
salaire au lieu d'une allocation de
principe
les élus soient pouvoir consulter les
habitants de leur commune pour les
décisions importantes par exemple pour
l'institution d'un référendum
le programme de blue air prévoit un
certain nombre de dispositions répondant
à ces voeux limitation des interventions
de l'état
les loisirs la culture l'urbanisme les
transports la voirie l'éducation par
exemple resterait de la compétence des
communes un minimum de ressources sera
garanti aux municipalités et les
collectivités pour un fixer elles mêmes
leurs impôts locaux dans les limites de
la loi les communes de france souffre
d'une centralisation excessive
il s'agit de leur restituer une partie
des pouvoirs et ce n'est pas facile ça
pour l'instant que le compte rendu du
conseil des ministres vient d'être
communiqué alors tout de suite nous
trouvons à l'elysée bruno masure pour ce
compte rendu
eh bien oui de communication une
décision sur laquelle nous reviendrons
avec fiat le porte parole de l'elysée
tout d'abord une communication de madame
simone veil le ministre de la santé sur
la politique des médicaments une
politique qui va s'organiser dans trois
grandes directions tout d'abord
l'amélioration du contrôle technique des
médicaments avec également un
renforcement de la publicité médical du
contrôle de ces publicités une tentative
une politique de freinage de la
consommation consommation médicale qui
s'est tout même un peu ralenti en france
ces deux dernières années mais qui reste
encore trop forte et qui grèvent le
budget de la sécurité sociale
enfin une politique des prix de cette
industrie pharmaceutique autre
communication celle de monsieur monory
le ministre de l'économie sur la
politique de la concurrence qui est le
complément de la politique de libération
des prix ainsi que la défense des
consommateurs notamment là aussi un
renforcement de la publicité et des
services après vente et puis également
le président de la république a demandé
à monsieur bah comme il l'avait annoncé
lors de sa conférence de presse
d'engager des entretiens avec les
leaders des partis politiques de la
majorité de l'opposition sur le
financement des partis politiques et la
limitation des cumuls des mandats
effectifs et puis également monsieur est
une décision je le disais tout à l'heure
le relèvement du minimum vieillesse à
partir du 1er juillet qui passera de 11
sans de onze mille francs à 2000 francs
pas ça c'est à dire mille francs par
mois pour les personnes âgées
c'est une mesure très importante parce
qu'elles touchent environ deux millions
deux cent mille personnes isolées âgées
et qu'elle marquait le président la
république a souligné au cours du
conseil des ministres la solidarité
nationale avec les démunis et le
défavoriser pourra toujours dire qu'on
peut faire plus est ce que on peut vivre
en france alors 78 avec 1000 francs par
mois oui comme vous le savez le
programme de loi a prévu une
augmentation sur 4 en deux sets de 7-6
minima vieillesse c'est donc le première
étape qui est franchie au 1er juillet et
bien entendu d'autres étapes seront
franchies
voilà clos pirard pour l'essentiel de ce
conseil des ministres merci bons
résultats du commerce extérieur français
pour le quatrième mois consécutif en mai
le montant des exportations 29 milliards
et demi a été supérieure de 155 millions
à celui des importations grâce notamment
au développement des ventes françaises
de céréales et d'automobiles en un an
les exportations ont augmenté de 15 % et
les importations de 9,7 pour cent
en visite à madrid le premier ministre
du danemark a déclaré que l'intervention
militaire de la france et de la belgique
au zaïre était une nécessité pour ces
deux pays pour en guérir gunson les pays
démocratiques doivent cependant agir
avec beaucoup de prudence afin de ne pas
s'ingérer dans les affaires intérieures
des pays africains le président sadate
n'envisage pas une nouvelle rencontre
avec menahem begin car ce dernier at il
dit adopte la ligne dure de la vieille
garde cependant pour le président
égyptien tout le processus de paix peut
être très vite remis en marche en
irlande
quatre hommes dont trois membres de
l'ira provisoire ont été abattues la
nuit dernière à belfast par une
patrouille de l'armée les quatre hommes
s'apprêtaient à déposer des bombes dans
un bureau de poste italie à gènes
assassinat ce matin de l'ancien chef des
services antiterroristes monsieur
esposito était à la tête du commissariat
de police de nervis dans la banlieue de
gênes l'attentât a été revendiqué par
les brigades rouges
le pape paul vi fait aujourd'hui le
casier ma nniversaire de son élection au
pontificat
une évocation de son rôle à la tête de
l'église avec bernard chevalier un règne
déjà respectable
15 ans c'est la moitié du pontificat le
plus long de l'histoire et bien sûr des
spécialistes ne cesse de scruter les
faits et gestes de l'épaule 6 mais ce
qu'il faut retenir de ces quinze ans
c'est l'action d'un pape attaché aux
traditions et soucieux en même temps de
moderniser l'église car paul 6 c'est
bien qu'un peu partout dans le monde des
catholiques manque de tonus prennent des
distances vis-à-vis de l'institution et
se lance aussi dans des initiatives
hardies alors le souverain pontife
s'efforce de sauvegarder l'unité de
l'église et du même coup se refuse à
condamner à excommunier et comme il
croit l efficacité des contacts humains
il rencontre volontiers les responsables
des autres églises ou religion chaque
audience avec les fidèles venus à rome
bureau donne du dynamisme car paul 6
doit s'accommoder d'une santé qu'il a
toujours eue très fragile et une
arthrose à la hanche qui l'empêchent de
marcher 15 ans de règne et 81 ans paul
si c'est toujours à la tête de l'église
certains pensaient qu'il démissionnerait
à l'âge où les cardinaux n'ont plus le
droit de vote pour élire à pontife
c'est à dire 80 ans elle est même
aujourd'hui déplore cette ambiance de
fin de règne qui envahit le vatican mais
le pape tient bon car il veut poursuivre
les réformes qu'il a entreprises celles
de l'administration centrale de l'église
il entend aussi s'appuyer sur les
églises du tiers monde qui font preuve
de beaucoup de vitalité pour redonner au
catholicisme à l'impact réel dans le
monde
et puis ball 6-7 avare de confidences
homme de devoir fidèle en amitié il l'a
montré récemment lors de la ferme moore
il n'aime pas qu'on s'intéresse à sa vie
privée
pour lui l'essentiel est d'assumer la
succession de saint-pierre temps que ses
forces physiques et spirituelles le lui
permettront si les sénateurs suivent les
députés dans leurs projets tout
conducteur de véhicule automobile
pourrait être soumis à un contrôle anti
alcoolique même s'il n'a pas commis
d'infraction ou ci n'est pas impliqué
dans un accident le contrôle sera fait à
l'aide d'alcootest mais le conducteur
pourra demander à ce que les
vérifications soient faites par analyse
examens médicaux alain peyrefitte le
garde des sceaux a précisé à ce sujet
que le gouvernement prendrait toutes les
dispositions pour que les appareils
utilisés soient parfaitement fiable
l'alcool est en effet le principal
responsable des accidents de la route
enquête éric gilbert
l'alcool reste bien le tueur numéro un
sur les routes de ce côté là aucun
progrès n'a été enregistré depuis dix
ans en 1977
treize mille personnes sont mortes
victimes d'accidents de circulation près
de 6000 de ces décès sont à mettre au
compte de ce que l'on appelle
l'imprégnation alcoolique
si en ce moment même on effectue un
contrôle routier
on s'apercevrait que un conducteur sur
30 roule avec +20 g 80 d'alcool par
litre de sang
et qu'un automobiliste sur 70 a pris le
volant avec plus de 1 g de ce qui pour
certains est déjà le seuil de l'ivresse
une analyse plus serré a été effectué
pour le compte de l'hôpital de garches
cette étude portant sur 3423 accident
mortel a montré que la moitié des
automobilistes impliqués dans ces
accidents comme victime ou responsables
avaient plus de 2 grammes d'alcool dans
le sang
sur le plan financier l'addition est
lourde pour la collectivité
l'alcool au volant août 14 milliards de
francs chaque année mais personne et
pour cause n'a encore pu chiffrer les
dégâts causés aux plans humain et social
c'est importante ce que vient de dire
éric gilbert ce vote de cette nuit
robert pietri en fait c'est le résultat
d' observation très précise de quelqu'un
qui s'occupe de ces questions du
professeur go c'est cela oui c'est vrai
il faut aussi bien sûr citer tous les
services de police de gendarmerie de
prévention routière de sécurité publique
et routière les assurances etc mais
vous avez raison le professeur go et son
équipe spécialisée ont travaillé dans un
premier temps sur la région parisienne à
l'ouest de paris dans la région de
versailles
chaque dimanche soir et chaque lundi
matin le professeur go qui est un
chirurgien recevait des centaines
d'accidentés de la route
il a donc été très sensibilisé il a fait
une première étude et s'est aperçu avec
stupeur que un français ou plutôt qu'un
accidenté sur deux n'était pas victime
directement de la route met de l'alcool
dans un second temps monsieur go et son
équipe ont travaillé sur l'ensemble de
la région parisienne et enfin dans un
troisième temps sur des statistiques
nationales fournies par les services de
la gendarmerie nationale
hélas le résultat était encore plus
stupéfiant éric gilbert
il faisait allusion tout à l'heure un
français sur deux accidentés les deux
voitures n'est pas victime de la route
met de l'alcool mais alors quelles sont
les nouveautés de cette loi est bien etc
outre l'aggravation des peines donc le
pire à parle et il ya un instant et ses
peines vont je vous le rappelle jusqu'à
la suppression l'annulation pure et
simple du permis de conduire il faut
parler de ces nouveaux appareils qui ne
sont pas les alcootests qui ne sont plus
l'alcootest de papa qui a vécu et qui
était composé je vous le rappelle très
rapidement d'un embout d'une ampoule
contenant un produit qui réagissait à
l'air porter d'alcool et enfin d'un
ballon désormais nous aurons à faire et
c'est le garde des sceaux qui il a
appris cette nuit donc à l'assemblée
jose affaire à un nouveau type
d'appareil qui est identique sinon égal
pour faire allusion au sujet du
baccalauréat qui ressemblera à
l'alcootest mais qui sera beaucoup plus
perfectionnés donc la radio viable et il
s'appellera l'analyseur d'haleine c'est
à dire que l'on ne peut pas vous en
montrer malheureusement car ils sont
fabriqués en dehors de francs sont les
fabriquera en france seulement vers la
fin de l'année ils entreront en fonction
sur les routes dès le début de l'année
prochaine il
il s'agira de souffler la également dans
un appareil par un embout est un tube
mais l'air expiré passera par une série
de pastilles contenant différents
réactifs à l'alcool et il y aura une
mesure extrêmement précises du taux
d'alcool au dessus de zéro g 8
il y aura bien sûr
prise de sang mesures très précises dit
tout robert pietri mais il n'empêche que
tout de même il y aura un recours
oui il y aura un recours c'est à dire
que il faut dégager la philosophie de
cette nouvelle loi
je pense que les députés l'ont déjà fait
les sénateurs ont également le faire le
député le groupe qui a proposé cette loi
a voulu non plus sanctionné non plus
réprimer comme c'était le cas jusqu'ici
puisque on vous faisait subir un
alcootest au moment d'un accident de la
route mais ils ont voulu au contraire
prévenir il s'agit bien de prévention à
tout moment avant un accident en dehors
de tout accident
on pourra vous faire souffler dans cet
analyseur d'haleine et donc vous éviter
de commettre un accident bien merci
regard robert pietri attention donc
après un déjeuner ou un dîner on atteint
très vite le taux d'alcool la suite de
l'actualité maintenant avec claude
bérard l'enquète sur le naufrage de
l'amoco cadiz à londres le commandant du
pétrolier a fait de nouvelles
révélations notamment que le commandant
du remorqueur ouest allemand pacifique
avait menacé de larguer le câble de
remorquage si l'armateur de l'amoco
cadiz ne lui consentent est pas des
conditions financières particulièrement
plus avantageuse il a également précisé
que la ligne de remorquage avait cédé
car elle ne convenait pas à ce type de
travail
après 10 heures de confrontation les
écologistes de l'association greenpeace
sont parvenus à empêcher un baleiniers
islandais d'art tu connais des baleines
le navire de greenpeace est en place
depuis maintenant le 4 juin tremblement
de terre ce matin dans la région de
salonique en grèce le premier bilan fait
état de 20 morts et plusieurs centaines
de blessés
à salonique dont nous recevons ses
premières images à l'instant la plupart
des victimes se trouvaient dans deux
grands immeubles qui se sont effondrés
la plupart des habitants ont quitté la
ville pour se réfugier dans des villages
aux alentours ou même sur les plages
l'évacuation totale pourrait être
ordonnée car la terre selon les
spécialistes pourrait de nouveau tremblé
en grèce du nord
quatre jeunes algériens irradié sont
soignés à paris vous savez dans le
laboratoire de radio pathologies de la
fondation curie créé il ya 20 ans pour
régler les problèmes de diagnostic et de
thérapeutique des irradiés et
décontaminer il faut signaler qu'il
n'existe qu'à seul autre laboratoire au
monde de ce genre il est situé aux états
unis
à paris à la fondation curry doux ce
qu'a déjà ont été traités à laure olga
faute n en quoi consiste le traitement
que l'on effectue actuellement il faut
savoir que la radioactivité est un
organisme de deux manières différentes
soit de l'intérieur
lorsque l'air est pollué par exemple par
des poussières radioactives et elle va
atteindre les poumons par exemple c'est
ce qu'on appelle la contamination soit
par une source extérieure précise qui
atteint enveloppe externe de l'organisme
d'une façon plus ou moins profonde celle
irradiation et c'est dans ce cas que se
trouvent les quatre personnes
actuellement hospitalisé à la fondation
curie la première chose que les médecins
essaient de savoir avant de décider d'un
traitement c'est l'importance et la
nature de la radiation subi or dans le
cas des quatre personnes algériennes
on ne connaît pas encore exactement les
circonstances de l'accident
une équipe de physiciens est partie
toute affaire cessante en algérie car le
temps presse pour reconstituer en un
temps record les conditions de
l'accident
évaluer la dose émises ce qui leur
permettra de savoir également comment
cette dose a été distribuée sur
l'organisme des personnes atteintes si
les brûlures sont superficielles ou
profonde si elles sont localisées ou
généralisée un des problèmes majeurs
avec la radioactivité c'est qu'elle est
invisible et qu'on ne la sent pas en
attendant les malades actuellement
hospitalisé il y a deux enfants parmi
eux ont reçu les soins d'urgence ils
sont placés en milieu stérile et on a
nettoyé leurs plaies deux possibilités
se présentent maintenant aux médecins
soient les malades vont récupérer en
quatre à six semaines avec un traitement
très approprié est très suivi soit si ce
n'est pas le cas et que la moelle
osseuse est définitivement détruites il
faudra envisager une transplantation de
moelle et trouver dans ce cas des
donneurs compatibles les conséquences à
long terme des irradiations lorsqu'elles
sont très fortes ou très localisées
peuvent être la cataracte la stérilité
chez l'homme un retard de croissance
chez l'enfant à cause des cartilages de
conjugaison par exemple la perte
définitive de certains membres et
certains radio cancer qui peuvent
apparaître 20 30 ans plus tard mais nous
n'en sommes pas encore là
oui cette radioactivité était je vous le
rappelle provoquée par un appareil qui
n'est pas plus haut qu'un stylo un coup
d'oeil sur la météo j'ai saint paul vous
excellent et et vous allez voir que le
bulletin ne le confirme pas puisque cet
après midi des nuages vont envahir
progressivement le nord-ouest du pays
donnant des pluies et localement dans
l'intérieur des orages et les
températures
deviendront plus fraîches ailleurs qu'en
même temps ensoleillé mais orage isolé
des pyrénées-orientales aux alpes et à
l'alsace pour demain toujours un temps
très nuageux et plus frais sur la moitié
nord ouest du pays avec des pluies
éparses ou des averses et il deviendra
progressivement très nuageux sur le nord
avec des pluies qui seront souvent
orageuses surtout en montagne et on
notera encore une baisse des
températures
les sports on connaîtra les deux
finalistes de la coupe du monde de
football à l'issue des quatre matches
qui se disputeront ce soir et cette nuit
tf1 d'ailleurs vous proposera italie
hollande en direct à partir de 18h35
et c'est pour cette raison que le
journal de roger gicquel vous sera
présenté à 20h30 avant italie hollande
là des envoyés spéciaux de tf1 en
argentine fait la bonne odeur ici on
respire enfin un peu mieux la coupe du
monde dès véritablement entré dans sa
phase active
d'après lé match entre l'italie et
l'allemagne après l'affrontement entre
l'argentine et le brésil
voici en quelques sortes le troisième ou
plat de résistance entre la hollande et
l'italie alors revenons tout de suite la
ville de mendoza quartier général des
hollandais mendoza qui est la ville la
plus éloignée du mondial elle est située
à 100 km de buenos aires à une centaine
seulement de la frontière chilienne
il faut s'y faire les résidences et
comme entraînements sont de petites
forteresses où les journalistes ont
accès par intermittence seulement après
avoir montré patte blanche qui somme
toute normal puisque l'entraîneur
hollandais ernst happel a plutôt un
visage de boulder relatera semaine que
le hidalgo lambé sur le grill et il ne
peut cacher une certaine lassitude ses
troupes résonne brink et rep en tête
sont heureusement encore bien fraîches
ap
mais
quelques fausses notes mais sur le
terrain une très belle harmonie comme ce
paysage au pied de la cordillère des
andes ou le corse johnny rep se sent
tout à fait à son aise
non je ne suis pas dépaysé en langues
et puis ici c'est souvent ensoleillé
comment va la hollande génie merci très
bien et nous sommes maintenant assurés
de terminer parmi les quatre premiers
empruntant lalonde a conforté sa
position mais elle a ressenti aussi
quelques frissons face à l'allemagne
heureusement que rené van de kerkhof
passée par là et obtenait une
égalisation aussi superbe offre que
méritée pour la hollande reste
maintenant affronter l'italie les
italiens ont plus droit à une aubade
imprévus ont fait aujourd'hui ici en
argentine la naissance du drapeau bleu
et blanc et devant ligne de clubs 5000
jeunes recrues ont effectué une ultime
répétition
claudio gentile et que pensez vous de
votre adversaire hollandais je n'ai pas
facile par l'italienne lac et
hollandaises leur allons-y là ça va être
très difficile c'est une équipe très
très forte et nous craignons de ne pas
faire d'aussi bons résultats que
précédemment
où en est le moral des italiens voilà la
moto bon moral il est très bon depuis
notre succès sur l'autriche et nous
savons surtout que si nous ne gagnons
pas nous risquons de tout perdre
l'italie avait été impressionnante aux
produits premier tour elle a semblé plus
récemment à court de souffle un seul but
devant l'autriche alors les bleus se
retrouveront-ils devant la grande aux
langues
un livre maintenant pour la première
fois un dissident chinois parlent ils
s'appellent cia feeling
il vient d'écrire un hiver froid à pékin
aux éditions altal édition elle passe
est un roman de politique fiction sur la
chine d'aujourd'hui mais avec une
particularité importante à travers cette
fiction l'auteur avait prévu prédit la
plupart des événements qui ont secoué la
chine
très récemment l'auteur a quitté son
pays en 1963 il est âgé de 46 ans il est
réfugié à tokyo où le correspondant de
tf1 jean marc perez l'a rencontré
l'auteur a préféré ne pas se mettre face
à la caméra pour des raisons de sécurité
vous allez le voir
voici ce qui pour quoi donc ce titre
l'hiver le plus froid de pique
c'est un outil chine yantai euros le
désordre qui régnait dans le pays
pendant les années 70 l'idiotie de l'onu
arrive à son point culminant 1076 son
gros kong est une petite bande de
dirigeant au sein du parti convient
chinois recours contre le peuple aux
méthodes de répression les plus féroces
pour le peuple chinois
il n'avait alors ni démocratie ni
liberté ni vérité n'est wenzhou gp car à
cette époque que j'ai choisi l'hiver est
par nature froid ne fait encore plus
cette année là qu'est ce que c'est être
chinois en 1970
layton ce team sport média le plus
important demeure la libération de la
france et qui n'est toujours pas totale
king le peuple éprouve la répugnance
pour ses campagnes politiques trop
souvent répété et dont l'enjeu est en
fait le pouvoir et non ce prétendu choix
entre les lignes
en dessous le peuple aspire aujourd'hui
en période de calme où toutes les
volontés seront mises au service du
développement économique et de
l'amélioration du niveau de vie window
mao est il vraiment mort et que
représentent-ils aujourd'hui mance dont
lentilles aux oublis dessous d'un
meeting soit transmis l'époque où mao
dominé à disparaît avec lui ou contre la
pensée aux méthodes qu'il alléguait
elles peuvent servir des individus de
bords opposés league
pendant les dix dernières années l'imsa
horizons de toutes sortes de procédés on
avait fait un dieu est dieu inspire la
crainte il est sans défaut sinon
restitue à mao sa nature humaine alors
l'homme a nécessairement des défunts du
dessous et croate
mais certains croient pouvoir se servir
encore des dieux votre roman était à
l'époque de la politique fiction vous
avait prédit le complot du gang des 4
comment avez vous réussi cet exploit
inouï itx est sourde face à tout parce
que le développement de toute chose a
une limite je crée en voir la preuve
dans les événements de la place
tiananmen le 5 avril 1976 la première
démonstration spontanée de coaching
on pouvait dès lors prédire la fin
inéluctable
la petite bande de madame après une
autre tentative intéressante et la
farine tiao qui va être le sujet central
de votre troisième ouvrage va-t-on
savoir enfin la vérité sur cette affaire
ce sera ambiance paiement sont bio
car en réalité les pillards d'abord est
utilisé par mao avant d'être écartés
libyen ne se trouvait pas dans l'avion
tombé en mongolie il n'a pas cherché
refuge en union soviétique
chez assouline en vous opposant
communisme chinois vous opposez aussi à
la chine
n'êtes vous pas un traître à votre
patrie au
aux hommes et aux nombreuses
j'ai agi par attachement à la patrie au
peuple chinois gardé le silence sur les
défauts de celui qu'on aime n'est pas
l'aimer mais le flat iron mines un hiver
froid ou à pékin aux éditions alta donc
en fait l'auteur sont deux d'accord avec
les autorités chinoises actuelle toutes
les difficultés et tous les remous
venait de la fameuse bande des quatre
dirigé par la veuve du président mao tsé
toung
la bourse de paris maintenant avec
françois de natty à l'avant de paris au
contraire le climat se réchauffe un
petit peu les valeurs françaises
connaissent une majorité de légère
hausse à tendance s'améliore sans doute
parce que cet après midi les députés
vont commencer la discussion du projet
de loi organisant une détaxation un tour
aux achats d'actions
le dollar vu en train est en baisse vous
avez une aiguille elle mais aussi
vis-à-vis du franc à 458 en huitièmes il
baisse de plus de 1 centime les valeurs
françaises elles ne se laissent pas
atteindre par ce vent froid venant de
voies structurantes poulenc et en os et
puis surtout peugeot citroën à 372
peugeot citroën qui a confirmé qu'elle
était la première société exportatrice
de exportatrice de france
les valeurs exportatrices aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs sont elles aussi en général
en hausse skis rossignol notamment monde
de 15 francs à 1520 francs en annonçant
que sans doute pour l'exercice 78-79 son
chiffre d'affaires progresserait de 18%
hausse également sur des valeurs à haut
rendement comme l'os un bus ou comme les
socialistes comptent conventionnés
hausse sur les valeurs exportatrices
comme russel de classe ou moi tu n 6
roussel uclaf d'ailleurs bénéficie peut
être bénéficiera peut-être des décisions
prises aujourd'hui au conseil des
ministres concernant la politique des
médicaments lord oncle est en hausse
sensible sur les marchés étrangers à
paris deux kilos à 27 1690 fait entre 80
et 100 dos et le napoléon à 259 187,1
francs 10 de hausse les valeurs
étrangères sont très irrégulières les
allemands de continuer à monter comme
7,4 plusieurs semaines les valeurs
américaines au contraire à la suite de
la baisse de wall street sont
renversants silva paris et les mines
d'or sont irréguliers
les valeurs indexé sur l'or sont
irréguliers a elle aussi car si le 4 et
10 % 373,7 148 francs est en baisse de
1.50 au contraire de 7% 1973 après 1149
en fait un bond de cinq places et c'est
la bourse avoue gérard saint paul merci
françois de natty merci à vous d'avoir
suivi ce journal n'oubliez pas ce soir
roger j call 20h30 après le match italie
hollande sur tf1 la famille